the Peppermill a popular staple on this
trip is celebrating 50 years of dishes
service and memory I love the pepper
mill many a good meal there a large meal
too it's a big plate oh my goodness it's
a large entree Mary Jane bellies it
takes a look at the history and what
makes the pepper mill so iconic to Las
Vegas
in the heart of strip you can't miss its
neon signs and packed parking lot
located off Las Vegas Boulevard and
Convention Center Drive the Peppermill
Restaurant is a testament of its time
still standing in its original location
which was once surrounded by big name
casinos like the Stardust and Riviera
the Peppermill opened its doors December
26 1972 and has become a favorite staple
for many over the years once inside
you're transported back in time with its
retro but modern day decor and Fireside
Lounge which has served as a backdrop in
numerous films and TV shows like casino
and Giada at home
executive chef Nicholas orth says
there's a place for everybody not only
locals and tourists come but celebrities
like Floyd Mayweather and Chris Angel so
literally the day that I was born my
parents brought me in here and had
breakfast after and my mom happens to be
the general manager my dad's worked here
uncles named every member of my family
has worked here previously in the past
so pepper Mill's in my blood so this
place has celebrating 50 years of just
an amazing experience for my family and
everybody else also known for its huge
portions of food and unique atmosphere
locals like Harry Spiro keep coming back
for the Nostalgia I've been coming here
for 47 years
and the first time I came here was 1975
and I had a Denver omelette and 47 years
later I had another Denver Opera I
brought my kids with me so show them the
history of this place uh this place
hasn't changed our waitresses are still
wearing the same uniforms got to keep
bringing them here and my grandkids
like to see those omelettes to celebrate
its 50th Pepper Mill is having a party
Monday morning at 9 30. there will be
cake balloons and food specials and
they're expecting special guests
including Penn and Teller you can join
the celebration again at 9 30 A.M